riesenüberraschung wer hätte das gedacht
unsere groko sie lebt von wegen die
können nicht regieren
in der nacht von montag auf dienstag
dieser woche gab es die große einigung
in deutschland dürfen ferkel weitere
zwei jahre ohne betäubung kastriert
werden
ich dachte das kommt an aber wir haben
viele zuschauer aus niedersachsen es
hilft nichts ja es ist ja meiner kein
witz es ist kein witz das haben sie
beschlossen beschluss der groko ist
jetzt blöd für die ferkel aber die
kriegen dann später bestimmte hardware
nach rostock ja ach ja bevor ich es
vergesse und dann gab es eben dann
nachts auch noch eine einigung im diesel
streit vorgestellt von den beiden
zuständigen ministern schulze um scheuer
und das war wirklich die mutter aller
luftnummer ist nicht übertrieben
verbindlich beschlossen wurde nur die
sogenannte umtauschprämie neuer und co
schenkt den betrügern zur strafe noch
ein konjunkturprogramm ganz toll und
jetzt kommt direkt der beste wird der
sendung eine politik
weil die der bosse zu sein
sondern der kunden der fließband
der berühmte arbeiterführer meine damen
und herren die auto aktien sind am
dienstag direkt hoch gegangen das sagt
ja wohl alles mein gott scheuer
er fragt man sich wirklich gut bismarck
auto der feiert sich jetzt für seine
umtauschprämie man kann überhaupt nichts
umtauschen man kann sich neun diese
kaufen und kriegt ein bisschen rabatt
ich glaube wir müssen das prinzip
umtauschen nochmal ganz grundsätzlich
erklären also nehmen wir mal an ich
kaufe meinem sohn in der tierhandlung
für 20 euro ein meerschweinchen zu hause
merke ich dann das arschloch aus der
tierhandlung hat mir gar keinen
meerschweinchen eingepackt sondern eine
ratte und dies auch noch tot
dann gehe ich natürlich zurück zu dem
arschloch in der tierhandlung und der
muss mir jetzt kommt entweder ein
meerschweinchen geben oder meine
verdammten 20 euro zurück das nennen wir
tauschen was an die scheuer vorschwebt
ist dass ich dem arschloch aus der
tierhandlung noch mal 20 euro gebe und
er gibt mir diesmal eine tote katze
das nennt man nicht umtauschen
das nennt man bis jetzt meine damen und
herren
ganz einfach
um den tauschen
ganz ehrlich wirklich gerne umtauschen
will ich den verkehrsminister dafür
zahle ich sogar auch mit rabatt können
sich viele leute in deutschland kein
neues auto leisten sind jetzt total
gekniffen
denn die von der kanzlerin großartig
versprochenen hardware nachrüstungen die
kommen ja nicht ja bmws raus opel ist
raus vw sagt machen war aber nur wenn
alle anderen auch mitmachen das kannst
du vergessen hier an die scheuer
erzählten wird vw kunde geht zu seinem
vw händler mit seinem passat und fährt
hin und sagt ich liebe zwar meinen alten
papa was hast du mir anzubieten und sagt
vw 5000 euro und machen die ein angebot
dann fragt ihr kann ich heute nach osten
dann kann der kunde entscheiden dass er
in seinen vw passat in der verliebte ist
auch hartmann nachrüstungen brüller die
lacher waren noch draufgelegt genau wie
bei der blöden heute-show siehst du die
leute sind nicht in ihr altes auto
verliebt die können sich kein neues auto
leisten gilt der dienstwagen hinten
sitzer beziehungsweise kumpel der
fließbandarbeiter entsprechend sauer
natürlich auch die opposition
und dass sie zügig nach drei jahren
auseinandersetzung dafür sorgt dass
jetzt klar
was war das denn immer wer hat denn da
das interview sabotieren der hand das
war ja klar das war
an
es ist ja wirklich nicht mehr zu glauben
überlegen sie mal drei jahre geschlagene
drei jahre macht die groko nix in sachen
diesen nichts und dann holt er sie in
einer nacht ein sagen wir mal konzept
auf dem bierdeckel
ja das kann doch wohl nicht wahr sein
dass das ist wie hausaufgaben im bus
machen
so werden garantiert keine fahrverbote
verhindert das sagen alle experten
und wenn die fahrverbote nächstes jahr
kommen gibt es auch noch ganz
merkwürdige ausnahmen für alte euro vier
und fünf diesel die die im realen
betrieb weniger als 200 70 milligramm
stickoxid pro kilometer ausstoßen wie
das gemessen und überwacht werden soll
ist noch unklar
ach klären was später wenn zeit ist 270
milligramm liegen übrigens 50 prozent
über dem erlaubten gesetzlichen
grenzwert dann können wir die grenzwerte
auch ganz abschaffen das wäre ehrlicher
auch völlig ungeklärt ist wie bei
fahrverboten kontrolliert wird wer in
die stadt einfährt
die polizei hat dafür garantiert kein
personal wahrscheinlich sitzen dann
demnächst so rentner in frankfurt einer
straße und schreiben alle
nummernschilder auf
ja das wird super und was sagen jetzt
eigentlich die leute die uns den ganzen
diesel mist eingebrockt haben wir
schalten wir live zu saskia lindemann
engelhardt sprecherin des verbands der
automobilindustrie frau lindemann engel
hat wie kam denn der groko diesel
durchbruch bei ihnen an
herreweghe wissen sie es wäre schön wenn
die schmutzkampagne gegen sauberen
deutschen diesel mal zu einem ende käme
und mit dem was wir den kunden jetzt
anbieten gehen wir wirklich an unser
absolutes limit und wir haben eben auch
eine soziale verantwortung
also wir vor dir seit dienstag durch
wann und schwanken
das war wirklich die letzte woche er war
ja wir sind ja wirklich mit der allem
durchgegangen der bahn sind diese
komische umtauschprämie zum beispiel
entsprechend exakt den rabatten die
unsere händler sowie so lass ich mal
ganz kurz jedes interview fertig also
der scheuer verkauft den leuten unsere
standard rabatte als familien so
schmerzfrei der typ neulich rufin an jo
an die halter einspritzpumpe wir haben
keinen bock auf hardware nachrüsten
erkläre das mal den leuten und dann
stellt er sich stumpf ins fernsehen und
sagt auch mit einem nobelpreis für herta
nachrüstung kann ich technische themen
einfach nicht politisch lösen wenn es
nicht möglich ist haben wir nachzulassen
und sendet dann geht's halt net haut er
einfach so raus ohne rot zu werden
dabei bauen bmw und daimler in den usa
schon seit jahren diese mit scr
katalysatoren
ach ja aber warum wir nicht bei uns das
kann man doch überhaupt nicht
vergleichen
die amerikaner haben und sehr regelrecht
unter druck gesetzt mit anwälten und so
das geht da drüben langsam schon
richtung faschismus das deutsche
kraftfahrtbundesamt genehmigt seit über
zehn jahren dreckige diesel also das
nennt man gewohnheitsrecht man kann ich
einfach mitten im spiel plötzlich
anfangen die regeln anzuwenden wir auch
wo abobo regeln 80 der neuen sauberen
euro 6 diesel überschreiten auch
deutlich die grenzwerte denke deine
mutter überschreite die grenze
auch nur in schwarz und spaß nein
natürlich sind die meisten euro 6 auch
dreckschleudern nach und die
verschrotten wir 2009 10 bei der
nächsten umtauschaktion das machen wir
jedes jahr so an die schreibt uns gerade
das passende gesetzt
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ich muss jetzt wirklich schluss machen
wir hören ja selber dass die party
eskaliert alle leute
[Applaus]
[Gelächter]
[Musik]